eu bater outra vez
a dúvida agora que seja normal ninguém
pega na cara de ninguém e fere um prato
de comida embaixo uma pessoa com
palavrões anuncia que estará em cartaz
até mostrou as consequências dos
conhecimentos e preto e branco mas será
uma solução ou suficientes pois bem
conhece casos um triste que as pessoas
foram arrancadas dos seus laços com o
pouco que se pode chamar de seu
está bem filho foram atiradas para um
lugar longe do problema sem o conforto
sim isto fugir mas se há suficientes
foram levadas para lugares opositores à
sociedade que mostram isso
hoje voltaram empurrar nas escadas como
esse não chegasse a 0 dentro da casa de
banho e bateram fiz queixa do empurrão
nas suas gentes foi na brincadeira as
mesmas brincadeiras todos os dias como
em muitas vezes é confundido como
brincadeiras piadas senhores não estamos
muito selvagem para que pequenas opções
e lutas sejam necessários ao crescimento
uma criança
se fosse assim nós devemos ser mais
policiais visto que esses dados são
verbal present nos cruzamentos das
crianças
essas opções rivais são conhecidas como
brincadeiras piadas dizer sempre faz
além das bocas sim eu posso é a mesma
coisa todos os dias mas isso aí entra o
coração não é fácil nem as moquecas que
vai resolver o problema
e quando nós temos maior e essa roupa
foram as palavras começaram no dia do
fato comentários estúpidos
sinto me feliz todos os dias só noite
sim noite outra vez
não existe a única maneira de sempre
viva
somos mais jovens quer dizer quando
somos mais velhos
hoje minha idade era um especial porque
não existe uma máscara está presente em
julgamentos comparações atitudes muitas
outras coisas são essas pequenas coisas
que eu mais uma jovem e essa relaxamento
acaba pulos nova vida e nós pensamos que
somos um falhanço começamos a falhar na
escola e as coisas começam uma bola de
neve gigante quando a minha constou na
minha idade
o nosso maior objetivo é sermos aceites
pelos populares semus aquela pessoa
tópico a gente adora mas muitas vezes
não dá
muitas vezes nós temos feridos nessa
tentativa e não digo que ficou
justamente no final - mas também
fisicamente não é que a adoção de ser
espancados por uma pessoa mas somos nós
que nos planeta maltratamos nós próprios
como com a automutilação um tema
estávamos na minha idade é um tema que
pode ter este ano passado mas que está
muito presente agora eu tenho muitos
amigos para que - por grupo de 10 e
muitos deus passa aqui - 56
tal como deus é muito triste nós
pegávamos está nossa amiga é sorrir nos
planos bastelo puxar a manga e ver aqui
o programa horrível eu conheci casos que
são simples como por exemplo um corte
mais de 500 peças como a saída é um gato
no muro mas com esses casos que têm nos
vaz em sanga e basicamente uma riqueza
dos riscos mais animadora em consolava
isso é muito triste
é muito triste josh pensar os campos e
os nossos filhos são pessoas sérias e
não estou é mal de ninguém mas que chega
uma escola e consegue achar uma pessoa o
nível de fazer ela sangrava
nós não estamos a fazer chorar estamos a
fazer sangrar de taça nós próprios
chegada a um ponto do carro já pessoa e
dizer torno validada e
pessoa assim que tanto isso que não
aguenta não agüenta o seu coração e não
se baseia se nas lágrimas mas sim no
sangue escorre eu tenho uma imagem que
sinceramente é uma imagem que eu mais
adoro as minhas lágrimas eu saiba os
olhos as minhas lágrimas sempre o meu
braço em forma de gota de sangue
é muito triste
basicamente é isso que eu quero para a
outra alteração mas que não consegue
sozinha eu preciso de apoio eu preciso
de dinheiro que me ajuda nessa batalha
diante do conjunto
eu tenho que fazer
estava eu na minha vida normal 8º ano e
vai grupo de crianças sem que se situam
volta disso a volta da criança eu fiquei
porque deve estar a brincar mas comecei
a tomar mais atenção
eu só vou usar aquela criança eu ia a
criança a incluir nos cacifos e senti
que eu fiz fez diferente
não cheguei lá ele só voltou com pressa
para aí não sei lá eles as vossas
palavras podem virar o que sim
as vossas palavras vai pirar lâminas a
pessoa ou as palavras claras e da
oposição não consegue exportar mais
aquelas palavras que vamos cortar o
pagamento foi quando essas crianças 6º
ano
elas foram embora não me disseram nada
porque já não existe respeito porque as
oitavas 6º ano já não existe
basicamente nós damos uns com os outros
e fico querendo só tem 14 anos mas há um
eco leva o quinto velho e respeito mas
já não existe
para quem tem filhos de francisco que
para proteger aquela vez e eu fui embora
foi com a criança e elton como caso
sentida mas agradeceu porque já não sabe
aguentar muito disse
nunca nunca nunca corte sempre falou
qual é e sempre faz diferença não seja
tipo a fazer caixa e bocas
eu cozinho faça em frente mas vou usar
acho que me importa o preço do fruto
nós todos acordarem e sou honesto mas
prontos básica - eu é que falar em
vários problemas pessoais e domésticas
bullying e automutilação
falar de sanções não falei porque porque
vejo vossas funções e passou espero
vossas ideias
basicamente existem muitos cartazes ele
joga muito no céu mas acredito que um
dia mais difícil nós conseguimos
já existe um cartaz e dizem idéias
negativas que as pessoas não sabem lidar
e preços com destaque para vir comigo
escreveu em novas funções e desde frente
é trás do cartaz na porta em branco que
toda a gente ignora eu sei que nós
conseguimos juntos